a little cough may be the least of the
worries of these villagers and yet it's
the biggest concern of aid workers it
could be a sign of the coronavirus a
threat these villagers fleeing attacks
from armed groups have not heard of
until they arrived at this food
distribution centre where extra
precautions are being taken she knows a
terrible Accord
our habits have changed because of this
disease now we wash our hands more
regularly with so before eating or
drinking we strictly follow the sanitary
rules that they taught us to avoid the
spread of the virus next to this relief
center is an international gold mining
operation where there are a number of
infected workers but production hasn't
stopped the value of gold is rising with
so much uncertainty in the global market
traders are investing in gold and
Burkina Faso is one of the world's the
biggest exporter but it has little to
show for all the wealth created Burkina
Faso has just 11 ventilators for twenty
million people and is ill-equipped to
deal with the outbreak hospitals and
clinics are closing down after threats
of attack by an al-qaeda affiliate in
the Islamic state in the greater Sahara
two groups which have stepped up their
operations despite the pandemic the few
hundred doctors left are abandoning
their posts leaving the people of
Burkina Faso alone to deal with a virus
that's rapidly spreading kina Faso is a
ticking time bomb this crisis is
revealing how fragile vulnerable and
weak some countries in West Africa are
during a pandemic
more specifically the Sahel countries
faced with the challenge of armed groups
the United Nations is calling for global
ceasefire so countries like Burkina Faso
and its people crushed by the violence
of armed conflict hunger and poverty can
better fight a virus that is quietly
gaining ground
Nicholas Hawk al-jazeera